le projet de loi comportant le respect
des principes de la république est
examiné depuis une semaine un projet de
loi à l'origine controversée qui visait
à lutter contre le séparatisme
islamistes mais qui finalement n'a
déclenché que très peu de polémique à
l'exception peut-être une tribune hier
dans libération signée par divers
syndicats et associations
ils s'inquiétaient que le contrôle
renforcé des associations à l'origine
visant les collectifs islamistes
puissent se retourner contre toute
association en menaçant leur liberté un
inquiétudes d'ailleurs partagée par le
défenseur des droits
il faut également noter la colère des
députés républicains en début de semaine
qui s'indignaient de voir la plupart de
leurs amendements rejetés pourtant
certains sont passés comme celui qui
crée un délit d'entravé à la fonction
d'enseignant l'est pas c'est d'ailleurs
grâce au vote de quelques députés de la
majorité
on écoute à cet égard françois cormier
bullygeois qui évoque ce soutien apporté
aux enseignants mais cette fois que nous
votons sur le respect des principes de
la république c'est une loi de liberté
c'est surtout noix de protection et donc
nous avons décidé dans l'article dont il
est question de renforcer la protection
des fonctionnaires de ceux qui assurent
des missions de service public pour
qu'il ne puisse pas être victime de
menaces ou d' entrave de pression et
nous avons décidé avec quelques
collègues de la république en marge de
soutenir l'amendement présenté par notre
collègue et d'art qui augmente la
protection pour les enseignants aussi
parce que nous avons besoin de soutenir
nos enseignants qui sont des piliers
essentiels de notre république
compte tenu de la nature de leurs
activités mais aussi parce que nous
légiférons après l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit moi j'ai conscience que beaucoup
de professeurs notamment d'histoire vont
aujourd'hui
leur collège et d'un lycée avec la boule
au ventre et je veux que ça cesse mais
donc je veux qu'il soit protégé je veux
que dans les cours d'histoire ou
d'instruction civique
il ne puisse pas être menacés ou remis
en cause au regard de l'enseignement
qu'ils diffusent je veux qu'on puisse
parler de liberté de conscience de
liberté d'expression de d'esprit
critique de la shoah ou de tout autre
sujet sans être remis en cause ont
menacé ou encore pierre donc nous avons
créé dans cette loi nous l'avons
renforcé par l'abondement cette
protection pour nos professeurs de
l'enseignement public notamment les
députés de la commission utah examiné à
large spectre de propositions allant de
la protection de la neutralité du
service public jusqu'à la lutte contre
le mariage forcé le texte sera débattu
dans l'hémicycle à partir du 1er février